[Musique]
il doit inaugurer ce bonjour bonjour
alors vous êtes candidat sur le sud la
4e circonscription et voir avec votre
suppléante natalia guillois pompière
vous êtes connu pour avoir porté l'une
est la leur la l'unesco c'est ça
exactement
qu'est ce qui motive qu'est ce qui a
motivé votre candidature
alors tout simplement ce qui a motivé ma
candidature c'est que depuis depuis une
dizaine d'années je milite pour le
rayonnement de la martinique alors
effectivement il y à laguiole qui on l'a
pu faire inscrire à l'unesco mais il ya
aussi la création du de la station de
métro aimé césaire et devant toutes les
problématiques qu'on a menti nique
je pense que nous avons besoin de toutes
les forces vives eaux pour vous faire
pour porter des propositions parler de
la station de métro aimé césaire est à
l'origine également exactement donc vous
surfez sur cela vous surfez sur les
réussites de laguiole pour vous
présenter alors certainement pas lorsque
vous parlez de laguiole laguiole m'a
appris beaucoup de choses ou du moins le
monde de laguiole pour moi le monde lève
ses mots de valeur l'entr'aide la
solidarité et surtout le dépassement de
soi et pour moi lorsqu'on doit une
comédienne promouvoir lorsqu'on doit
lorsqu'on veut le développement de la
martinique
on est déjà dans le registre de
dépassement de soi c'est pourquoi
j'estime que pour aider la martinique on
doit faire appel à toutes les forces
vives de la martinique d'ici et
d'ailleurs votre mot d'ordre si la santé
globalisé ça veut dire quoi elle
effectivement la santé globalisé vous
allez comprendre
j'ai la chance j'ai une chance dans ma
vie c'est ma mère
et ma mère elle m'a inculqué les valeurs
des valeurs humaines
et dans notre programme on vous remet au
centre de nos intérêts lui mais
ça veut dire que
l'a senti est à la base de tout la santé
humaine santé physique mentale l'a senti
économique la santé de l'environnement
une société saine
et c'est en cela qu'on propose ce
concept de sentiers globaliser le
personnel soignant qui s'est mobilisé
depuis la crise qu'ovide est ce qu'il
faut le réintégrer cela va de soi cela
va de soi parce que ce qui sera les
conditions quelles que soient nés ou bas
quel que soit ce qui compte le plus
si le fait de prendre soin de la santé
des martiniquais on a besoin de ces gens
si jenson vital pour la santé des
martiniquais
l'environnement aussi ça fait partie de
vous de votre programme alors simplement
nous lorsqu'on se promène ou lorsqu'on
est dans sa voiture
je pense que ça choque tout le monde
deux voies dédiées des vieilles voitures
des épaves laissé à l'abandon
des dédits peau comment dirais-je un peu
partout sauvage c'est je pense
inadmissible pour notre martinique et
chacun de nous doit prendre ses
responsabilités c'est pour cela que dans
notre programme l'environnement fait
partie deux points très importants
vous parlez dans l'économie qu'il fera
qu'alléger les contraintes
administratives des petites entreprises
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire vous
parlez de l'octroi de mer de tout ça
qu'est-ce qu'il faut qu est ce qu il
faut aller j alors pas sûrement pas
seulement leur toit de merde sur le
point fiscale avec ce tout ce qui se
passe en ce moment avec l'ukraine et où
toutes les augmentations s'il y a bien
des entreprises qui crient famine si
bien aux petites entreprises
et vous savez bien que on parle souvent
des des grandes entreprises
mais s'il y a une sous une des
entreprises qui sont les plus importants
c'est bien les petites et moyennes
entreprises
ouvrir le droit au chômage pour les
professions indépendantes et libéral est
ce que il ya de l'argent à foison en
france pour permettre
le paiement du doigt de chômage aux
professions libérales
je dirais tout simplement nous bien
trouver la japan djokovic qui veut plus
si le gouvernement si l'état veut se
donner le moins 10 10 ces professions on
peut le faire
luttez où vous avez alors un volet
social de votre programme notamment en
termes de lutte contre l' isolement
social
alors effectivement je pense que en
martinique nous avons un problème de
vieillissement de la population il y a
beaucoup de personnes âgées qui se
retrouve seul vous savez on dit si vous
voulez savoir comment une société sera
demain
regardez comment entrer ces personnes
âgées
est aujourd'hui en martinique je pense
que on n'a pas fait le nécessaire c'est
pourquoi dans mon programme au moins un
point d'honneur comment dirais-je
apprend dit qu'on doit proposer des lois
pour envers les personnes âgées et
surtout les idents familiaux parce que
je pense que on n'a pas fait le
nécessaire
et doit être inauguré je vous remercie
merci
[Musique]